on this
um let's uh joining us for labor this
morning is Jess Phillips um hi Miss
Phillips always great to see you what
are your thoughts on these barges
I think it's just another ridiculous
gimmick and I think I think the thing I
want to make clear is that this isn't
instead of the hotels this is as well as
the hotels and this particular barge uh
you know we're talking about sort of 0.3
percent of the current uh not not three
percent not point three percent of the
the current backlog what I don't
understand
um is uh it just seems a very unusual
thing not to have spoken to the local
Authority as you said the mayor the
labor party tried to get the government
to vote that into law that local
authorities uh where these sites and
hotel sites would be held would have to
by law be consulted with and the
government voted against that last week
um it just it just feels to me I have to
say that they just want you to have this
image of this barge for your news
broadcast so it looks like they're doing
something but this is a I mean excuse
the pun a tiny drop in the ocean and
they should get on with clearing the
backlog of the 166 000 cases what does
labor believe will happen with these is
it a floating prison and are those on
board will not be allowed off or is it
as the locals are worried about uh 500
people who they don't know coming in and
out of their town and going as they will
and damage challenging their services
every 28 days
your guess and Labor's guess is as it is
uh as good as mine I I don't know what
the situation is going to be and uh you
know the minister didn't seem to be able
to answer those questions I I have
absolutely no idea certainly as a member
of parliament who has a number of hotels
uh in our area that house uh Asylum
Seekers and refugees and the general
homeless population because there's also
nowhere for those people to go
um I have to say we get no I mean
usually the home office will email you
in the morning when they've moved a load
of people there in the middle of the
night so and those people are certainly
allowed to go out and about like you
know they're not they're not imprisoned
they're allowed to move around the local
area just by my office
um you know the the there is a number of
different hotels so yeah I don't know
the answer to your question and I don't
think the home office now I certainly
wasn't much clearer after I'd spoken to
the minister I think in all fairness I
can say that
um you know that officers are being
taken away from protecting the country
against terrorism uh in order to look at
internal standards 200 met officers were
being told what's Labor's reaction to
that
look I think the the an operational
decision has been made by Mark Rowley to
try and uh
turn around what can only be described
as an absolute crisis of confidence
within the Metropolitan Police and I
assume that he's taken all of the
necessary risk Assessments in fact I
don't assume I I feel like I'm certain
that Mark Rowley knows what he's uh
doing
um but unless with the Metropolitan
Place and I have to say police forces
across the country turn around uh the
sort of crisis in confidence in in
policing currently they actually won't
be able to do their job properly at all
in in any area and I think that the Home
Secretary needs to come out much
stronger and talk about what she's going
to do about standards in policing
because at the moment it's a hodgepodge
situation across the country where it's
different all over and I think we need a
little bit of leadership
and what you want to do is have
specialist course that will deal with
rape cases yeah so you know today uh the
labor party is uh basically having found
that half uh well it has doubled since
2015 the number of rape victims dropping
out of their trials it's gone from 19 in
2015 to 41 of rape victims who come
forward drop out of their trials uh and
some of that uh is undoubtedly down to
the massive weight the average weight is
three years for a rate trial to come and
so the labor party wants to see
specialist rate courts uh being set up
to fast-track these cases to stop uh
victims dropping out and to ensure that
we can lock up some rapists that would
be nice
um it seems like quite an old-fashioned
desire to to want to see some rapists
charge the current rate is 1.6 of cases
are charged at the moment and that is
just absolutely woeful the labor party
also wants to see end-to-end victim
support uh and legal support for victims
as soon as they come forward and
specialist rape units in every police
force which the government has voted
against your boss keeps getting himself
in all sorts of trouble all it's tying
his self in knots when he talks about um
Single Sex spaces and uh transgender
issues
um what's your view on um Single Sex
spaces
I mean I used to run them so um for many
many years I ran women's refuges so I
think that Single Sex places should be
protected not just uh through our
equalities laws and that needs to be you
know I think that there is a need to
look at how explicit the equality act
currently does say that it is sex that
is the protected characteristic not
gender uh but where that has led to some
uh confusion I think that you know it's
worth looking at how we might want to
clarify that
um but you know what what I am
absolutely certain of is is that not all
women are the same and you can't just
say Single Sex spaces uh the answer for
example I used to run specialist Single
Sex bases for South Asian women in
Birmingham and I'd want to see
specialist spaces uh for transgender
victims of domestic abuse but I
absolutely believe in Single Sex bases
for women's only services and actually
we've seen a massive degradation of that
in the last 10 years under this
government who claim to care about it
but have actually seen the undermining
of specialist domestic abuse services to
generic Services pretty much everywhere
in the country okay just before I let
you go um you know whatever uh the the
flavor when it comes to politicians
politicians go into being a politician
because they want to make a difference
but quite often you've got targets uh
quite often you're a Target as a result
and I see that you've been openly saying
that you you need to take medication for
anxiety because of the level of threat
against you do you want to talk more
about that
I mean yeah they look I mean who knows
whether my anxieties are you know
pattern of my age and uh other things
but you know I unders I have suffered
trauma uh being a member of parliament
uh without doubt I don't think it's that
unusual to uh suffer from anxiety when I
was about to swear then kay I'll try not
to do this uh yeah I'm in all sorts of
trouble
um that uh I don't want to I'm not gonna
swear don't worry but my dad used to
basically say just because the rotors uh
uh just because you're paranoid doesn't
mean the writers aren't trying to get
you uh but he said it more sweary but
um the the truth is is it feels like a
huge amount of pressure sometimes uh and
you are under attack as a member of
Parliament and there's a difference
between scrutiny uh and attack but don't
worry about me uh I'm a twofold bird
oh it's always great to see you thanks
very much indeed enjoy the Easter as
best you can thank you